monkey pox is a rare disease caused by a
very tiny germ called the monkey pox
virus
it belongs to a group of closely related
viruses called orthopox virus
other viruses in this group that can
infect humans include the variola virus
which causes smallpox the cowpox virus
and vaccinia
monkey pox is a zoonotic disease this
means it can spread from non-human
animals to people
you can catch the virus through close
skin-to-skin contact especially sexual
activity with a person who has monkey
pox symptoms
if you have sex with someone who has
monkey pox it's important to know that
using a condom alone probably won't
protect you from Catching the disease
this is because the virus can also
spread through contact with rash on
non-genital parts of the body body
fluids including droplets in their
breath and surfaces or objects they have
used such as their clothes and bedding
and a pregnant woman who has monkey pox
can pass the virus to her unborn child
but scientists aren't sure if a person
who has monkey pox can spread the virus
if they don't have symptoms
once the virus enters your body it
travels through your lymph vessels two
nearby lymph nodes where it begins to
multiply
over the next one to two weeks the virus
spreads in your bloodstream throughout
your body
during this time called the incubation
period you won't have symptoms
you may be at a higher risk for catching
monkey pox if you have had close skin to
skin contact within the last two weeks
with someone who has or may have monkey
pox especially with men who have sex
with men in a geographic area where
monkey pox is spreading or have a job
that may expose you to orthopox viruses
such as lab workers and healthcare
workers others at risk include those who
have had contact with animals such as
monkeys or rodents that could be
infected are exposed to objects or
surfaces contaminated with the virus or
have not been vaccinated against
smallpox if you were born after 1972
chances are you did not receive the
smallpox vaccine like most viral
infections monkey pox may start with
flu-like symptoms including feeling
exhausted chills
fever
headache muscle aches swollen lymph
nodes and a stuffy nose sore throat or
cough these symptoms are usually
followed by a flat rash on certain areas
of your body such as the genitals anal
region face mouth hands feet and chest
then the rash can turn into raised
pimple-like sores that are filled with
fluid or pus and the rash is often very
painful
this rash generally lasts for about a
week before beginning to crust scab over
and finally falling off with the
appearance of Nu Skin
if you think you might have symptoms of
monkey pox or want to find out more
about it talk to your health care
provider